To find the side link of a cube, we actually take a cube root of the volume. So
the cube root of eight would be the cube root of two cube. We need this factor
of two of third in order for us to take it out. Since this index is a three, we
need to group the three factors to take out the two from the radical symbol. A
cube root really just send us a third power. We can think of roots and powers
and inverse operations of one another. Pretty neat, huh? We can apply the same
concept for taking the cubed root of 125. We see that a factor of five appears
three times underneath the radical, so we just have five. And for the cubed
root of 343, we just have seven. Here is the list of some perfect cubes. These
numbers are considered to be perfect cubes since we can take the cube root of
them to get an integer. Like we saw before, 8 was the same thing as 2 cubed. So
the cubed root of 8, or 2 cubed is just 2. You'll want to keep a list of these
perfect squares and perfect cubes close by since they come up frequently. Make
a list on a separate sheet of paper or use and index card but either way you
want to be really comfortable with your perfect squares and your perfect cubes.